an alarming new report alleges sexual
predators are using popular dating apps
and other users have no idea the report
exposed screening discrepancies between
match groups free dating apps including
tinder OkCupid plenty of fish and also
the paid service match.com one woman
told us she was raped on her first date
by a convicted rapist she met online
Mikki batiste shares her story their
serial rapists and this is how they prey
on their women
Janine Dunphy says she met mark Pappa
Michel in 2014 on the free website
plenty of fish and when she agreed to a
date she had no idea he was registered
as a sex offender with three prior rape
convictions dunphy says she and Papa
Michael learned they had mutual
connections so after their first date
she felt comfortable going to his house
I went Gees the bathroom after that and
he was hiding behind the door when I got
out of the bathroom and he threw me
across the bed and that was the end of
it
Dunphy filed a police report alleging
Papa Michael raped her he was held for
two years without bail in county jail
but was later acquitted by 2016 Papa
Michael was back on plentyoffish
where he matched with a woman who also
went on to tell police he raped her a
pending criminal case against him was
dropped in 2018 after the woman died of
kidney failure when dunphy matched with
Papa Michael plenty of fish was not
affiliated with match group now it's one
of several free dating apps owned by the
company which tens of millions of people
have used match group has promised to
screen against the sex offender registry
list for specifically match.com but has
not extended that to the rest of its
apps Hilary Flynn is with Columbia
Journalism investigations and in a new
story spearheaded by cji a match group
spokesperson is quoted as saying there
are definitely registered sex offenders
on our free products in a statement the
company said the article is inaccurate
and mischaracterizes match group's
safety policies the question is
is that we're asking should the company
be doing more match.com began screening
its subscribers against the National sex
offender registry in 2011 but match
group says that it is not able to obtain
sufficient and reliable information to
make a meaningful background checks
possible for users of its free products
Dunphy says that discrepancy needs to
change a simple background check would
have saved this whole thing from
happening for CBS this morning
Niki batiste New York we reached out to
the attorney for Dunphy's alleged rapist
and he declined to comment and in its
statement match group told us we do not
tolerate sex offenders on our site and
spend millions of dollars annually to
prevent monitor and remove bad actors
from our apps very frightening story
very very disturbing we reached out to
rain which is an anti sexual abuse
organization and they some helpful
reminders for people on these sites
always meet in a public place yes good
to know tell a friend or family member
where you're going that's important and
also if you find yourself in trouble
don't be afraid to reach out to a
bartender or a server and say hey I need
I need assistance